Let's do some problems with
plotting points and graphical
representations of functions.
So I didn't write the problem
here, but what they ask us to
do here is figure out
the coordinates of
each of these points.
So let's just do that.
So first we have this
point a right there.
So I'll just write a is
at the coordinate.
So we write the x-coordinate
first. So its x-coordinate is
how far to the left or the right
it is of the origin.
And it is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 to
the left, or it is negative 6
of the origin, or it's at the
coordinate negative 6.
So negative 6, that's
right there.
And then its y-coordinate, which
is how high it is, that
is right there.
That's 4.
Negative 6, 4.
Let's do b right there.
b is at the coordinate-- let's
see, its x-coordinate, and
just drop down there, is 7.
And its y-coordinate, how
high it is, is 6.
All right.
Let's do c.
The x-coordinate, and you can
read that, it's negative 8.
It's 8 to the left
of the origin.
Negative 8.
And its y-coordinate, it's
2 below the origin.
So its y-coordinate right
there is negative 2.
This is, I think,
not too painful.
Part d, or coordinate
d, or point d.
Point d, its y-coordinate,
it's at 4.
And then its-- I'm sorry, its
x-coordinate is at 4, and then
its y-coordinate, how far down
it is, or in this vertical
axis, it is-- this looks
like negative 7.
And then, finally,
we are on e.
I'm picking out a nice
color for e.
e right there.
Its x-coordinate is 5.
It's right on the x-axis
at x is equal to 5.
And its y-coordinate-- well,
it isn't above or below the
origin or the x-axis, so
its y-coordinate is 0.
You could draw a line and
go straight there to 0.
So there we go.
We figured out all of
those coordinates.
Now this problem 5 here-- let me
scroll over a little bit--
they say determine whether each
relation is a function.
So here the trick is to realize
that a relation is not
a function if they define two
values for a given x.
Let me give an example here.
So if I wrote that f of x is
equal to 5 if x is equal to 1,
or it's equal to 6 if
x is equal to 1.
This makes no sense.
Why doesn't it make any sense?
Because if I put a 1 in there,
I don't know what
I'm going to produce?
Am I going to produce a 5?
Am I going to produce a 6?
This is a badly structured
function.
This is not a function.
So if there's any situation for
the same input value, they
define two different output
values, we're not going to
have a function.
So let's see if they
do that here.
So in this first part, part a,
they say, if you could imagine
if x is 1 then y is 7.
If x is 2, y is 7 as well.
That is OK.
You could have two x values
getting the same y value.
For example, that'd be like
saying f of x is equal to 7 if
x is equal to 1 or 2.
This is completely fine.
For two different x values you
can get the same output value,
but you can't have two different
x values giving the
same-- sorry-- you can't have
the same x value producing two
different outputs.
Because then you don't know,
hey, if you went f of 1, you
don't know what f of 1 is.
f of 1, is it a 5, is it 6?
You don't know.
Here you know what f
of 1 is, it's 7.
of 2 is, it's 7.
So, so far so good.
So when you have 2,
you have a 7.
When your input is
3, you get an 8.
4, you get an 8.
So, for example, our function
definition, so it's 8 if x is
equal to 3 or 4.
And then 5.
And then our function is equal
to 9 if x is equal to 5.
So part a, this is our function
definition, right
here, for part a, which is a
completely legitimate function
definition.
You give me any value 1, 2, 3,
4, or 5, which would be the
domain in this situation, and I
will tell you what the value
of that function is at
any of those points.
And the range would
be 7, 8, or 9.
So part a is definitely
a function.
Now part b.
Let's see, if x is 1, y is 1.
But then they say, if x
is 1, y is negative 1.
Well, that makes no sense.
They're doing this right here.
They're trying to make a
function, where they say this
function is going to be equal
to 1 if x is equal to 1, but
then it's going to be equal to
negative 1 if x is equal to 1.
So if I were to take f of
1, I don't know what
it's going to be.
Is it 1 or negative 1?
I don't know, do I take this
1 or do I take that 1?
So this is not a function.
So part b is not a function.
That relation is
not a function.
All right.
Let's do a couple more.
Problem 6.
Write the function rule
for each graph.
So we have this little
v looking thing.
So we could write it
a couple of ways.
Let's call it f of x.
And you could call it g of x, or
h of x, but if you haven't
used your f yet, people
tend to use f of x.
So this is x.
So let's see, it looks like
it's one line when x is
greater than the 0, and
another line when x
is less than 0.
So it's one thing when x is,
let's say, greater than or
equal to 0.
And another thing when
x is less than 0.
And I'm going to merge
the two in a second.
So what does the line
look like here?
When x is 0, y is 0.
When x is 2, y is 1.
When x is 4, y is 2.
It looks like no matter
what x is, y is going
to be 1/2 of that.
When x is 6, y is 3.
So it's equal to 1/2x, when
x is greater than 0.
And then when x is less
than 0, when x is
negative 2, y is 1.
When x is negative 4, y is 2.
So here it looks like it's
the negative 1/2 of it.
Negative 1/2 times negative
4 is positive 2.
So it's negative 1/2 times
x, when x is less than 0.
So this is a completely
legitimate answer.
But if we wanted to make it a
little bit simpler, or clean
it up a little bit, we could
write this function definition
as f of x being equal to--
instead of dividing it between
greater than or less than 0,
let's just take the absolute
value of x and then multiply
that times 1/2.
Because here, that obviously
works for positive values,
because the absolute value
of x will be equal to x.
But then for negative values,
the absolute value of x is
equal to negative x.
So you take negative 2 here.
Negative 2, take the absolute
value, you get 2
times 1/2 is 1.
So either of these would
be legitimate function
definitions.
Problem 10.
Use the vertical line test-- let
me switch colors for this
one-- use the vertical line test
to determine whether each
relation is a function.
Now, the vertical line test is
just a visual way of doing
exactly what we did in this
problem over here.
Something is only a function
if for a given x value, you
only have one y value.
So for example, when they say a
vertical line, that means at
any point I should be able to
draw a vertical line on this
function and only intersect
it once.
Because a vertical line says
when x is equal to 3, there's
only one value that I can
get on our function.
That's what I'm doing with
a vertical line.
When x is equal to 0, there's
only one point on the function
that is mapped from
x is equal to 0.
So this one right here
is a function.
Any vertical line you draw
will only intersect the
function once.
This one, very clearly, you
draw any vertical line.
You draw any vertical line
here and you're going to
intersect the graph twice.
So this is saying, this vertical
line that I just
drew, this is essentially saying
f of 2 could be this
point over here.
This looks like, I don't know,
maybe it's equal to, it could
be equal to 1.9 or it
could be-- what is
this?-- negative 1.9.
This is not a proper function
definition.
I don't know whether f of 2 is
this value or that value.
I don't know whether f of 0 is
that value or that value.
And you could keep going across
the whole number line.
You don't know whether f of 5
is this value or this value.
So this is not a function.
This relation is
not a function.
And it's the same logic as we
did before, but we're saying
the vertical line.
You could draw a vertical line
and you can intersect the
relation or the graph twice,
so it's not a function.